oh okay i got you i got you i got you i
got you
okay okay okay okay i got you right all
right so okay i know where we're heading
all right
hi my name is john and i'm a former
walmart employee of nine years
hi my name is jade and i am a former
walmart employee of two years
hi my name is samuel swanson i'm a
former walmart employee of seven years
and today we'll be sharing our secrets
to help you shop better at walmart
tip number one the best time to shop at
walmart is
definitely during the week because the
weekends are very unpredictable
but if you do have to go during the
weekend the morning is your best bet
me i like late nights because most
people are asleep
you pretty much can shop and piece and
get whatever you want
now definitely when they don't restock
some storage stock daily
others a few times a week definitely
check that out
tip number two check walmart's website
before buying an item in store
guys have you ever bought an item
literally to get home to find an
ad on your facebook that it was like 12
cheaper sometimes you can actually find
better deals online than you can
in person so definitely price compare
because if you find something
cheaper they are more likely to match
the price for you
why there's so many checkout lines but
only a few of them are open
the reason behind that is self-checkouts
one
employee can run five self-checkouts as
opposed to
personally ringing you one person at a
time everybody that's in walmart unless
you're not a greeter or you don't work
behind the cashier
you're gonna always be in training to be
able to go and move different places
honestly like they want the guests to
use the self-checkouts
and eventually there won't be any more
checkout lanes at walmart
it's just a faster method of getting
people in and out as quickly as possible
tip number four
use coupons to save you money you can
find
plenty of coupons online from any
third-party websites
and the great thing about walmart is if
your coupon saves five dollars but your
item costs less than that
you actually get the difference back
towards your remaining of your purchase
so walmart is always killing it when it
comes to
deals guys save your coupons
tip number five walmart even accepts
coupons from competitors
now the only rule to that is the coupon
has to have an exact price to it
it cannot have a percentage like 20
percent off
tip number six shop walmart in-house
brands to save lots of money
the great value in equate brands are
actually quality brands with the same
ingredients
as some of the larger brand names that
you would see out there
from the cheese to the milks to the
juices
they even have bottled water guys tip
number seven
look for refurbished and clearance items
online to find
great deals a lot of people can't afford
a macbook
a lot of people can't afford apple
products refurbished electronics from
online
a lot of times they still have the
manufacturer's warranty you really
shouldn't have any problems with it
tip number eight there are some
prescriptions that only cost
four dollars walmart provides generic
prescriptions
just for four dollars and this discount
works for everyone
no membership required make sure you
check out for that because you can save
tons of money every year tip number nine
stay clear of store brand supplements
they are not worth it
sometimes they don't have the
ingredients necessarily on the label
they may not be as good of a quality or
brand as you would think
and guys trust me you don't want to eat
nothing you don't want to eat
so definitely you might want to splurge
on some of your supplements
number 10 don't bother with anything
organic
walmart is definitely about unbeatable
prices and deals but when it comes to
organic
i honestly wouldn't bother the other
grocery stores are
much better now we all know we really
don't know what we're eating familiarize
yourself with
what cross-contamination is because a
lot of times once some of those fruits
and vegetables touch other things
they're no longer considered organic so
i would definitely kind of look
elsewhere for that
tip number eleven look for day old items
to get great deals
definitely check out the bakery and meat
departments you can get bread that was
baked the day before at a great markdown
the same thing applies to meat whenever
they're one day old they always
mug them down the day old bread and some
of the discount meets
are going to be the same quality it's
just the expiration date so something
may be expiring a few days
sooner but you may be paying half the
price so it's actually a great deal
and i'm not going to lie when you got a
sandwich this loan
for four dollars who's not gonna eat
that
tip number 12 if you don't want to get
trampled on a black friday
we all know how there's usually a huge
line on black friday of people waiting
outside of the store
but you can avoid that by getting all
your stuff
online and get those same black friday
deals
you can sit back in your pajamas and get
the black friday deals
all day long and overnight shipping
boom free of charge tip number 13
there is a free grocery pickup option
you should use
grocery pickup is completely free you
can avoid making impulse purchases while
you're shopping through the store
and a walmart employee even load your
items into your car
for you it's quarantined people are
literally trying to stay
six feet so you can avoid lines avoid
the checkouts
and just sit comfortably in your
air-conditioned car while they bring
them out to you
tip number 14 walmart has its own
secret price tag code price endings with
seven it's typical the original price
so if you see a seven you already know
before you walk up to the register
give me your money price ending with a
five or zero are going to be the first
markdown
this price can be better but still may
not be the best you get
price is ending in a one or usually the
final markdown of the item make sure to
buy that item because it'll be the last
time
it'll go down and the last tip if you
don't want to remember that code
walmart does offer price protection on
items that you purchase within seven
days
so just keep that in mind there are some
exceptions though
so clearance items special buys black
fridays and cyber mondays
however most items do qualify for that
price protection
the special buyers values of the day
items oh damn oh this one
what you see i am popping
thanks so much for watching and i hope
these tips and secrets
help you be a better shopper at walmart
be a better shopper
save that money hey there buddy all
right that's it bro that's all i can
give out of you man
[Music]